we're almost twenty installments deep
into Nintendo's Legend of Zelda series
not counting those terrible CDI games
it's awful
mayor Cavendish has been changing the
towers oh my cake and we're still going
strong breath of the wild brought in
advanced buzz by the heart container
full and when fans finally play for
themselves they noted its balance
between originality and honoring the
overall Zelda theme but what some
players likely haven't yet noticed are
the exciting connections to Zelda's
legacy sprinkled throughout the game
does the dango still just like smoke are
empty jars to the weirdly rare commodity
in Hyrule will we ever figure out what
the dealers of this guy he has a look at
a few small details and breath of the
wild only true fans noticed location
location location since its initial
release over 30 years ago The Legend of
Zelda has been all about the lush
landscape and amongst those grassy
knolls and spooky caves are a few
structures that stand out easily one of
the most recognizable at spectacle Rock
which first appeared in the original
1986 release and has cropped up in later
installments as well the double mountain
appears again in breadth of the wild
where it can be seen in wide angled
shots from above but this time the
famous formation appears on a much
larger scale you might also recognize
ranch ruins of Lon Lon ranch from
ocarina of time and fans will probably
get chills when they run into the temple
of time again threat of the wild calls
back to those games that came before it
with a slew of other place names as well
sure they've shifted around a bit since
the 8-bit days but the names remain the
same even still the definitive Zelda
guide Hyrule historia has told us of
this theory splits off into multiple
timelines making everything even more
confusing single island - the riff on
the flamboyant Vanessa tingle who
appears throughout the series for ombo
Beach appeared in a slightly different
form in Link's Awakening and qohelet
Rock is a clear reference to Colin's
island from the same game
Mido Swampert grabs its title from an
obnoxious character in ocarina of time
and even more breadth of the wild
locations of straight out of The
Adventures of link
raro hillside Ruto lake and a farrier
among them all of whom were also
revealed as characters in our kareena of
time
and Lineback island takes its name from
the cowardly captain in the Phantom
Hourglass the secret language an element
of breath of the wild that has left
players scratching their heads as the
mysterious chica language used on
various items signs and descriptions
throughout the game while in sender
could have just given us a lot of
convincing gibberish like some kind of
sigur rós song these things actually
spell out words it's not hard to find a
translation key online and the players
have utilized it to decipher hidden
messages most interestingly one winding
bit of text that appears on the master
Edition boxed version of breath of the
wild reads the Hyrule fantasy in Reverse
true fans know that's the Japanese
subtitle for the original Legend of
Zelda the cool references don't even
stay within the world of Hyrule however
when installing new abilities to link
seeker slate impress of the wild sheekha
text scrolls down the screen some
phrases can be translated as now loading
and do not turn off your sleep but the
hilarious Easter Egg can be found in the
sentence that reads all your base are
this of course is a reference for the
mean worthy English version of zero
wings which are physically translated to
the game's original Japanese into the
jumbled up phrase all your base are
belong to us and well just in case
you've forgotten this eventually
happened all your base one day
then all your base are belong to us
thanks Internet omen or the monks of
breath of the wild have some unique
names but one sticks out omen or Arman
or as an anagram for aonuma and it just
so happened that AGA a Numa has been
working on Zelda games since Ocarina of
Time he's currently the series producer
and manager of the entire franchise so
it's a small way to immortalize a guy
who's already a bit of a legend the old
man one thing that isn't new in breath
of the wild is the old man who's clearly
a reference to that other old dude seen
in the original Zelda who gives link his
first sword and some ominous advice the
cryptic character shows up again in
breath of the wild again with a fire and
again in a small cave of course it could
be a simple coincidence we had old men
love caves after all
but then Nintendo stacked another juicy
Easter egg in there the sheikah letters
pouring out of light beacons you can
place hold a hidden message that links
players all the way back to the original
Zelda the secret words it's dangerous to
go alone just look at the flowers if
we're talking literal parallels to elder
Zelda games it doesn't get more literal
than this when viewing the Master Sword
in breadth of the wild shown on its
pedestal in the game's official III
trailer check out the flowers now
compare it to where you find the master
sword in the Link to the Past sure it's
just three well arranged flowers but
it's a fairly clear-cut nod to the
franchise's history whether or not it
means something significance is the
forum nerd arguments and YouTube
commenters to decide and the speaking of
the sword its links weapon grabbing
experience in breath of the wild shares
a lot of similarities to his journey in
a Link to the Past you'd think you'd be
able to tell a magical sword from a
piece of junk by now but no maybe he
knows a guy who can tell the difference
in breadth of the while the gamers can
grab what appears to be the Master Sword
fairly early on in the game where it
sits perched on a tall rock formation in
truth it's a rusty virtual broadsword
that will break shortly after you use it
a couple of times in a Link to the Past
link also believes he's stumbled upon
the actual Master Sword in the Lost
Woods which is weirdly filled with
of dummy's thoughts links things he's
found us a real blade when he pulls it
from the ground but it all falls to
pieces when it's revealed that it's a
total do next time just look for the one
that literally shoots lasers man thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love thing
[Music]